[Applause]
so
[Applause]
the lineup is set for life is beautiful
2022 the festival is returning to
downtown las vegas september 16th
through the 18th in downtown and here to
tell us more about it is the head of
music and programming craig neyman
welcome thank you for having me quite
the lineup this year congratulations
what a great job you guys did tell me a
little bit about putting together this
iconic festival it really has become
part of the fabric of las vegas yeah
absolutely we couldn't be more happy and
thrilled about this year's lineup it's
going to be our ninth edition in 10
years and this year it's all about fun
so you'll notice that from top to bottom
arctic monkeys are only playing a couple
shows this year in the united states
calvin harris hasn't really performed
many shows in the united states let
alone festivals yeah kelvin um kygo so a
lot of eating
yep we have jack harlow on hip-hop migos
beach house kg elephants coming back
allison wonderland's coming back jungle
still vanessa the list keeps going and
going going it's something you and i
were just talking about off the air a
lot of positivity in the performers
on this year's lineup and that's kind of
what life is beautiful is all about
bringing positivity and fun to las vegas
absolutely we hope that when fans come
through the gates for three days that
they're coming to have the best weekend
of the year and if we can help provide
as much fun as humanly possible and put
out those experiences book the artists
who are going to deliver those sets that
really grab the fans and and don't
release until the end and that they
leave with those memories that's that's
the goal well of course music is a huge
part of it but there's also
so much more to the festival tell us a
little bit more about what happens
during those three days absolutely we
have you know the festival itself has
many different pillars so our culinary
program is much more elevated if you've
been attending since 2013 you know we've
always had great restaurants from around
the valley we've had a great cocktail
program we also have an incredible art
program that we bring in artists from
around the world i think if you were to
step into downtown las vegas any day
throughout the year we have one of the
best open air art galleries that is out
there from street arts from around the
world and so we'll get those refreshed
this year we also add the elements of
the idea series we have components where
we have local vendors with market in the
alley through ferguson's there's a lot
of community
involvement now i did notice something
when the lineup was released you had the
big display but there were some names
that i don't know if that was a mistake
on your end there was some blurriness or
my eyesight is bad was there were there
some blurs on there i hope your eyesight
isn't bad
we just have a couple we just have a
couple more artists that um in time
we're going to be we'll be announcing
them okay see there there is one that's
announced that we probably can't say on
tv right now that one i didn't know who
that was but that was blurred out okay
and that one is um that's going to be a
performance that i think everyone should
want to see she if you look her up right
now in the news she's very heavily
involved in a lot of explanations yes
absolutely
really excited and now tickets they go
on sale friday yes tickets go on sale
friday at 10 am ga tickets are 380 plus
tax and fees we have vip tickets at
7.95 plus fees and there's also the the
layaway option so if you want to pay in
installments we do have that so we have
a little bit of everything got to go
check it out thank you so much kendall
over to you all right